Hallo, mein Name ist Katy Beslado,
ich bin Direktorin für IBM Quantum-Strategie
und Anwendungsforschung. Ich bin hier, um so viele
Quantencomputing-Mythen
wie möglich in sechzig Sekunden zu widerlegen.
Einer der wirklich schönen Aspekte ist, dass Quantencomputer real sind
und wir haben Geräte in der IBM Cloud, auf die jeder zugreifen kann.
Ja, aber nur für bestimmte Dinge, bei denen sie wirklich gut sind –
extrem komplizierte Mathematik, wie sie das Universum verwendet,
aber wenn du Tabellen und E-Mails bearbeiten willst, nutz
deinen PC.
Ja, theoretisch – aber noch nicht,
denn noch niemand baut einen Computer, der gut genug dafür wäre.
Für die absehbare Zukunft sind wir auf Kurs,
und wenn wir so weit sind, werden wir die Art, wie wir Informationen schützen,
grundlegend verändern.
Das ist völlig falsch – Quantencomputer
sind grundlegend anders
und nutzen die Naturgesetze zur Informationsverarbeitung.
Die heutige KI läuft auf guten alten klassischen Geräten,
aber wir glauben, dass sie in Zukunft zusammenarbeiten werden.
Das stimmt nicht – wir haben ein enormes Ökosystem
aus Startups, Hochschulen, nationalen Labors und Industriepartnern,
die unsere Geräte täglich nutzen.
Nein – quanteninspiriertes Computing gibt es schon
seit Langem und läuft auf klassischen Geräten. Es wird
das Versprechen des Quantencomputings nie einlösen.
Wenn du echtes Quantencomputing willst, brauchst du auch echte Quantencomputer –
keine Simulation.